what if someone says well I'm gonna be
30 in March so you know I'm just gonna
pack it in I'm not gonna make it here
what about this new pressure this 30
under 30 25 at the top you know people
in tech developing apps whatever this
this new bar that we've we've said that
where you have to be a certain age or if
you have it might as well pack it in
well the system is set up for the youth
and they assume that whatever older ones
of us have survived and then wizard mode
now is that we have is irrelevant
I just Pat I'm gonna build and a heads
and say good luck when I was a young man
there was a thought that was a saying I
never forgot it and it was when I was a
young man I thought my father to be a
fool now that I have grown older
oh how wise he has become it's when
you're young you think you know every
damn thing until life smashes you in the
face with the truth of its indifference
toward you and all those dumb people
that are you think are older and you
don't listen to I want you did a couple
of scars you'll see how stupid they
really are it's gonna be scarred first
you know because I'm talking and they
don't know nothing your generations in
the past but when you get crushed
and by crushed I don't mean by not being
successful asked what the cost today of
being successful is it's coming out so
you have success which paid for it and
so with that success comes shame because
she wanted the success more than your
self-respect you notice all these people
coming out now and saying this is the
price I've paid and I've been this
miserable for all these years but thank
God I can say me too and it took
something off of me can you imagine
being successful knowing the price you
paid and choking on it for the rest of
your life
hey everybody I'm just fine I'm just I'm
great and I don't care about what I had
to do except when I sleep at night I
can't sleep at night yeah what about
wanting notoriety
notoriety these days people will do
anything for notoriety some of things I
see on the internet cannot
I mean are they really doing this he
just pointed out to me yesterday a
friend of his is an artist has been
accused of sexual harassment of three
women can he point out to me one of
these women has a website and every one
when she has hundreds of pictures on our
website write the most obscenely
provocatively sexually explicit pictures
that you can imagine but a victim of
this dude was getting no due process by
the way because she said so he's guilty
a friend of mine worked at CBS for
fifteen years and a woman said that five
years ago he looked at her in a
suggestive manner that made her feel
uncomfortable they fired him on the spot
they don't want the publicity
so these days people do things I sexual
acts I mean this guy was on this
murderer was on and he put a selfie up
talking about how he killed people and
how he did it
he didn't use a gun because he wanted to
use a knife to and see them die slowly
and then there are little kids now
taking drugs and doing other kinds of
things online young girls
sexual acts bullying and saying how
brave I am and little girls going to
school 12 years old with guns in their
hunt their backpack and people getting
shot I mean I mean for nota right I
guess being famous now has taken the
place of any kind of self-worth as long
as you like me I'm okay
and godlike myself because you like me
but when you're alone doesn't that
bother you I mean I don't understand how
just having recognition or having people
know who you are having million eyeballs
I guess that gives you identity these
days and that's just beginning of the
next two generations